the average person eats about 40
kilograms of meat per year in developed
countries it's double that or about the
same weight as an adult dolphin what
experts now advise cutting down the
amount of meat we eat to help reduce
climate change so here's a thought
experiment what if the whole world
turned vegan around 15 percent of all
greenhouse gases emitted by humans are
from livestock production if you'll
became vegan these emissions would be
slashed eating meat takes up space a lot
of us and 80% of all farmland is
dedicated to meat and dairy production
that's about the size of Europe at the
US China and Australia combined nice and
dairy typically provide 18% of our
calories but account for 60% of
greenhouse gas emissions from
agriculture
a report by the UN's Climate body the
IPCC recommends we all reduce the amount
of meat we eat and also how much we
waste the report found 8 to 10 percent
of all global emissions are down to food
loss and food waste but not all meat is
the same large-scale farming of beef has
a particularly high impact and has been
a big factor in the loss of the Amazon
rainforest when cows digest their food
they produce methane a powerful
greenhouse gas that's about 28 times
more powerful than carbon dioxide
over 100 years and when calves burp this
methane is emitted one cow releases
between 70 and 100 kilograms of methane
every year when they're around 1.5
billion cattle in the world today what
is not as simple a lot depends on how
the meat is produced most meat is
mass-produced by large-scale industry
and this can come with a heavy
environmental impact but small-scale
farming of animals can have a lower
environmental footprint and sometimes
for it
in the case of traditional grazing it
can be beneficial in terms of
biodiversity vegan alternatives can also
come with their own problems for example
large scale production of soya can lead
to deforestation when almond production
requires huge amounts of water but if
everyone switched to a plant-based diet
it could bring several positive health
benefits one study estimated that if
everyone ate a vegan diet with lots of
fresh fruit and vege around 8 million
deaths could be avoided around the world
by 2050 there are no simple answers but
if everyone were to change how they look
at food cultivated and eat it in a
sustainable way we could potentially
change the world thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon